apple's wwdc event is happening in less
than one month and there's a good chance
we could see apple finally reveal their
m2 chip which is the successor to the
legendary m1 that completely
revolutionized the mac bringing it back
from the depths of intel despair but the
number one question that people have
right now about the m2 chip is this how
much performance are we actually gonna
get and what other benefits will we gain
in terms of features and everything else
so that's exactly what i'm gonna answer
in this video because we've got some new
leaks and rumors from the supply chain
that confirmed some very important
speculations about the underlying
technology we should be seeing in the m2
chip but before i get into all of that i
first got to go through all the leaks
that are pointing to this new m2 chip
being revealed at apple's wwdc in just
one month getting started last month
mark grumman released a report
discussing what to expect at wwdc and he
mentioned that apple is gearing up to
launch some new macs in the next few
months and what better place to do so
than wwdc specifically he was told that
there are two new macs coming around the
middle of the year or early in the
second half with one of them being the
new macbook air and the other
potentially being a new mac mini an imac
or a 13-inch macbook pro now these
details are important because mark
german is known as the most reliable
apple analyst and leaker and within the
last few months he's been telling us
over and over again that these new macs
will all be coming with the m2 chip as
early as january mark german mentioned
that a redesigned macbook air is coming
with a new m2 chip and then in february
mark said that at least four macs
powered by m2 chips are likely to launch
later this year yes that's four of them
now in march 9to5 mac came out with an
exclusive report about the new macbook
air and macbook pro coming with an m2
chip later this year despite sources
like minchikwo who said that this year's
macbook air redesign will come with the
same old m1 chip which i kind of
personally doubt and then in april mark
came out with another report claiming
that apple is already testing at least
nine new macs with four different m2
chip variants including three m2 max
some of which he thinks could be coming
at wwec in less than a month on june 6th
and just to add further evidence mark
mentioned that the upcoming ios 15.5
software update for the iphone is mainly
focused on bug fixes and adding
compatibility with some upcoming macs
now this is huge because we're about to
see ios 16 get revealed at wwdc but it's
actually not going to be going public
until later this fall when the new
iphone 14s are released so this
essentially means that apple is planning
on releasing some new macs before the
new iphones come out which is why we're
seeing compatibility being added to ios
15.5
greatly raising the chances that apple
launches new m2 max at wwdc now on the
other hand we did have some other
sources like leaks apple pro mentioned
that both the new m2 macbook air and m2
mac mini will be coming at wwdc now in
my opinion i honestly don't think it
makes sense for the redesigned m2
macbook air to come before the new base
macbook pro so because of that i think
that if we're getting new m2 max at wwdc
it'll be the m2 mac mini with a redesign
and then the m2 macbook pro 13-inch base
model without a redesign and the number
one reason why i believe this is because
back in february the leaker who got the
whole notch leak right last year said
that this year's new macbook pro is not
getting a redesign at all while mark
german believes the only big change will
be the removal of the touch bar but no
full redesign and this is very important
because if both the macbook air and the
macbook pro get the m2 chip it would
make sense for the non-redesigned
13-inch pro to come first before the
redesigned macbook air which i think is
going to come later in the fall and the
one piece of big evidence for this is
that back in march mark german tweeted
out that apple is testing an m2 chip
with an 8 core cpu and a 10 core gpu
with three different versions of mac os
and the key detail here is that mark
previously mentioned that the m2 chip
will also have a bend 9 core gpu model
which is almost certainly for the base
macbook air because right now the
current m1 air comes with a bend 7 core
gpu while the macbook pro and the mac
mini start with the full 8 gpu course so
the fact that mark german software
league pointed to the full 10 core gpu
m2 model being tested and not the 9 core
it points to apple releasing the full 10
core versions of the m2 first within the
macbook pro and mac mini and then
holding off until the fall to release
the macbook air with the bend 9 core gpu
m2 but now with all of that stuff out of
the way let's get right into the most
interesting part where we talk about the
performance and everything we should
expect in terms of the cpu mark has
already confirmed that it's going to be
coming with an eight core cpu using
essentially the same layout as the m1
with four efficiency cores and four
performance cores so any difference in
performance is gonna come from apple
increasing the clock speeds by using a
more efficient silicon node technology
from tsmc which is now likely believed
to be their n4p process which is
basically five nanometer plus plus plus
or the third gen of five nanometer
compared to m1 which used first gen five
nanometer and that difference alone
should translate to around an 11
performance boost according to tsmc now
in one of my previous videos i ran a ton
of calculations for m2 performance with
two different scenarios one being that
the m2 is based on the a15 chip and the
other being that it's based on the
future a16 chip that's coming this year
or more likely the other way around with
the a16 being based on the m2 so i'm
gonna include those calculations in this
video now looking at the single core
performance if the m2 is truly based on
the unreleased a16 chip we could see as
much as 2050
points in geekbench 5 which is
absolutely insane being on par with
intel's latest desktop i9 12900 ks cpu
now moving on to the multi-core
performance we could see it go as high
as 9
322 points which isn't as impressive but
it's still incredible for just four
performance cores and keep in mind that
it'll still be less powerful than
apple's current m1 pro chip because it
has two extra performance cores which is
honestly by design so it doesn't
cannibalize the higher-end macbook pros
but to be completely honest this is
still more than enough performance for
the average person and the beauty of the
entry-level m2 chip is that it's
actually going to be the efficiency or
the battery life that gains the most
because tsmc mentioned that their third
gen 5 nanometer should use 22 percent
less power than first gen at the same
performance level which is amazing and
this is basically going to give apple
the freedom to of course make the chip
faster but also make the max smaller and
thinner which would lead to smaller
physical battery sizes while not
sacrificing any of the battery life
compared to the current m1 max but now
with that said we've also got to address
the graphics performance and this is
where we'll see a big jump in
performance because this time we're also
adding in up to another two gpu cores as
you can see the m2 chip could see gpu
performance as high as 31
762
more than 50 higher than the m1 which is
very impressive
and it's gonna be a really nice sweet
spot for efficiency while giving users
just enough performance for playing
games and whatever else now other than
all of those raw performance numbers
there's a chance that we could see
hardware ray tracing come to the m2 but
i think it's more likely to show up in
the m2 pro and m2 max chips that are
coming next year and on top of that we
should be expecting more powerful neural
engines amx processors maybe more
thunderbolt controllers an upgraded
image signal processor faster ram faster
storage and other changes like that and
it's crazy to think that we could be
less than one month away from seeing
apple reveal the m2 chip at wwdc
so if you're as excited as i am let me
know in the comment section below and
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one and check out
one of those two right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]